the problem to me isn't freaking
increasing the age the problem to me is
we are no longer selling the values and
principles
that made america such a great country
where people around the world wanted to
come and raise their families here
that's the permanent problem adam and i
think that's what we're having issues
with when's the last time you saw
somebody like even
when's the last time you saw somebody on
fox or or msnbc or cnn just praying
when's the last time say hey i just
wanna do a prayer can we do a prayer
here's what i want to pray and you pray
for peace you pray for forgiveness you
pray for you know improvement you pray
for love you pray you i again i don't
this is boring stuff
none of us wanted to hear this stuff
from our parents when we were kids none
of us wanted to hear it but guess what
those who did benefited from it those
who didn't didn't benefit from it okay
so that's what i'm saying where i'm not
looking for like hey let's just pass
it's only going to take five percent